[MUSIC PLAYING]
DERK DE KORVER:
All right, folks.
Welcome, and thank you
for joining today's Google
talk with Matt Dixon.
Before we get
started, I would like
to ask everybody in the
room to mute their phones
and turn off any notifications,
as this is being recorded live.
So we don't want
any interruptions.
As well, I just
want to announce we
are expecting a lot of people
to join through live stream.
So if you do have
questions for Matt,
we have a 10-minute section
at the end where you'll
be able to ask those questions.
And I've set up a Dory
for people remotely.
And it's at go/coachdixon where
you can submit your questions.
So yeah, without further
ado, let's get started.
For those of you
who don't know Matt,
Matt is a world-class
triathlon coach.
He's also a former
triathlon pro.
And today, he's most well
known for creating Purple Patch
Fitness, which is a global
community headquartered here
in San Francisco.
As part of Purple
Patch, he manages--
I say manage, but
coaches a handful
of elite pro triathletes.
Just to name a few
which you might know,
Jesse Thomas, Sarah Piampiano,
Sam Appleton, Laura Siddall.
Laura Siddall actually went
on to win Ironman New Zealand
this past weekend.
So congrats, Matt.
As well as that, he coaches
a wide variety of age-group
athletes, so amateurs
like you and me,
ranging from the very elite--
he's helped over 250
age-group athletes qualify
for the Ironman World
Championships in Kona--
to the more average
athletes, who
are just seeking to
stay fit or conquer
one of their life goals.
And it's here where Matt has
really specialized his focus
on these athletes who are
time-starved, like you and me,
trying to fit in training in our
busy lives of work, family, et
cetera.
Now, Matt's a busy man, as well.
He does all that, and he's
also written two books.
He wrote "The
Well-Built Triathlete"
and most recently launched
the "Fast-Track Triathlete,"
of which you have a copy
here on your chairs.
Now, you might be
asking who am I?
My name is Derk de Korver.
I'm a I'm a fellow Googler
and also a triathlete.
And I'm part of Purple Patch
Fitness, and I train with Matt.
So yeah, so let's get started.
I'll give the
floor to Matt here.
Maybe you could
give us a little bit
of background about yourself
and how you created Purple Patch
Fitness.
MATT DIXON: Sure.
I am the epitome of
an example of how
to do a professional triathlon
career very, very poorly.
As you can tell, I'm
not from the States.
I actually came
across here in 1992.
And I was one of the sort of
lucky early, relatively early,
sort of guys that came across
on a swimming scholarship.
So my backbone or my
background was swimming.
And swimming is a sport
that, at least at that time,
was all about high
volume, higher endurance.
And I remember when we swam,
we weren't even allowed
water bottles on the pool deck
even though we were swimming
27 hours of swimming a week.
So it gives you some idea of
sort of the mindset back then
in the early '90s.
In parallel to swimming, I was
studying exercise physiology.
So right from the start, I
had this interesting blend
between sort of science and, of
course, being an elite athlete.
And when I finished my
swimming career, which
ended up not making the
Olympic team, the quest of most
internationals that
were coming over here--
we were trying to make
our national teams.
I didn't make it.
I was fifth or sixth.
That shows you how
long ago it was.
I can't even remember whether
it was fifth or sixth.
But that's where I
got into coaching.
And I started as
a swimming coach.
And I was very lucky to
actually start with a very, very
good age group program.
But I realized I
didn't want to be
a swimming coach, or at least
just in the regular setting.
So I went on to do my master's
degree in clinical physiology.
And so now I had this advanced
I went on to coach at
the division one level
while I was doing that.
And that's where
I found triathlon.
And I found out I was
pretty good at triathlon.
And so out of that, despite my
background of having a backbone
or background in elite swimming,
having a coaching background
already with several
years of coaching,
and a master's degree
in clinical physiology,
I went on to be the great
example of how to do
a professional career poorly.
And I took the work ethic
of swimming and thought,
well, if I was training
27 hours a week for a two-
to four-minute event,
what am I going to have
to train for an Ironman?
And so I multiplied it
as much as you possibly
could, with continued nothing
but lip service to subjects
such as recovery,
nutrition, fueling,
hydration, and had this
sort of small rise,
maybe a little bit of glory,
and then a staggering defeat
into chronic fatigue.
And interestingly, that
was a wonderful thing
that I think happened
for me, was the fact
that everything came to a shut.
And about 15 years ago now, my
professional triathlon career
was over.
And I was starting
to coach triathletes,
and that was really the
start of Purple Patch.
It was, bizarrely,
a positive thing.
DERK DE KORVER: Wow.
So you did a professional
career poorly.
How can that be
a positive thing?
MATT DIXON: I think it was one
of those situations in my life
that it forced me
to take a step back.
And I think so often,
we charge ahead
and we forge ahead with
our quest, especially
when, as an athlete, it's
a very specific quest,
world-class performance.
And so you can
filter out so much
of the things that are
right in front of you.
And when it's stripped away, as
with any sort of adversity that
can happen in life, it forced
me to take a step back and look
at the landscape of my sport at
the time, which was triathlon.
And what I saw was
at the elite level,
and particularly at
the amateur level,
I just saw so much
underperformance or low return
on investment
relative to the effort
that people were putting in.
And the barometer of
success at the time
was simply about the
accumulation of hours.
More miles, more hours,
the better it is.
And subjects which now are
quite trendy, but recovery,
nutrition, fueling--
everything was an afterthought.
And I just thought,
there must be
a better way of approaching
the sport globally.
And I looked at this
symptom of underperformance.
And what I saw at all
levels from people
that were beginning to get
into the sport with big lives,
as well as at the top
world-class level,
most athletes were showing up.
Motivation wasn't the challenge.
But they were showing up to
their races fit and fatigued.
And I thought, that can't be
good for ultimate performance.
And so with my
education background
and my own personal experience
and what I saw in my coaching,
I think it was really the
birth of the Purple Patch
methodology.
Because I decided at
that time to be a bit
counterculture against
the overall sort
of general theme of how people
would go about endurance sports
globally.
And I decided to make a
pretty bold move and say,
I'm going to go about it
from a very different lens.
And that was really,
I think for me,
the start of the Purple
Patch methodology, which
15 years later is still the
heartbeat of what we do.
And so I must have been
on to something, at least.
DERK DE KORVER: So that
must have been quite a shock
to the triathlon community,
a new way of thinking.
How would you define the
Purple Patch methodology?
MATT DIXON: It was a shock.
In fact, I got labeled
the recovery coach
because I bubbled that right up
to the top of the conversation.
A lot of my writing
was around recovery.
And it wasn't always
a positive name
that I was given, although
now it's sort of become
a badge of honor, in many ways.
And so I think the
methodology can really be
defined in very simple terms.
And as it lives now today,
there is a common thread.
So it doesn't
matter whether we're
talking about a world-class
athlete or someone that's
purely a fitness enthusiast.
Everyone wants to improve.
Everyone wants to thrive.
That's the common thread that I
see amongst fitness enthusiasts
to my professional athletes.
And what we have found is
that by integrating four key
components, what we
call the four pillars--
and there are more, but these
are the central four that I
think are omnipresent, and
that's endurance activity,
or training for your
world-class athlete,
but endurance activity
supported with some strength
and conditioning-- so
you have to have both--
and with adequate recovery.
And that encompasses
sleep, which
is a big, trendy
topic at the moment,
with a backbone of really
basic but important nutritional
habits.
When we get those four things
present, people thrive.
People accelerate.
And it's completely
regardless of level.
It doesn't matter what level.
Those four key components
are the basics.
Now, what we see a
lot is people that
are pretty good at being
singularly focused.
I really want to exercise.
But it all falls to
pieces if we don't
have all four elements
actually present
in people's sort of emotional
approach to life, in many ways.
And so I think that's the real
backbone and the very central
sort of thesis on everyone
that we serve, in many ways.
DERK DE KORVER: And by
everyone, you mean--
you've mentioned the
pros, as well as elites.
And I've experienced that
with training with you.
During our swim sets,
the pros are to the left,
and then we have all the
time-starved athletes sort
of in the rest of the lanes.
How is it different working with
these two types of athletes?
MATT DIXON: It is different.
It's a little bit Jekyll
and Hyde in some ways.
But at the same
time, it really comes
down to how you apply
those principles.
So if you can buy
in for a moment
that there are four
basic tenets that we're
going to be talking about--
endurance, strength,
and nutrition as a big
bucket, and recovery,
it's really how you
apply those principles.
So let's first
establish the mindset
of the professional athlete.
Their quest is unapologetically
world-class performance.
So what that means
for the athlete--
and that's who you
read about in magazines
if you're a triathlete,
whatever it might be.
But their quest is everything
around physical performance
is the centerpiece
of their life.
So my job as a coach
is to actually take
the other components of
life and suppress them.
It's kind of like a monk's life.
Because they are, for a
short period in their life--
four, eight, 10 years--
they are seeking
world-class performance.
And so components, like
obviously the training,
but nutrition, bodywork,
massage, et cetera,
the fueling, their
sleep, that is their job.
And everything else around life
has to be built around that.
That makes sense.
So that's what the quest is.
Unfortunately, many amateurs
apply that to their lives.
And that's when
failing comes in.
For the time-starved amateur,
most time-starved amateurs
that we work with,
fitness enthusiasts,
but all the way up
to Derk's level,
who's an athlete amateur,
the mission, I believe,
should be about integration.
So it's not about seeking
world-class performance.
You're actually
seeking more than that.
I believe that
what you're seeking
is integrating very basic habits
and an appropriate training
program so that yes, you
can improve and get fitter,
stronger, more
powerful, or, for him,
get ready for the
Hawaiian Ironman,
but not at the expense
of the other institutions
of your life.
And in fact, when we think
about working with an amateur,
we're trying to do two things--
help you thrive
in sport, but also
help you improve
your health, help
you improve how you can
perform at the workplace,
and be the best
version of yourself
that you can for your family,
friends, and everything else.
And by successfully doing
that, that defines the mindset,
I would say, of what
we're looking for.
So it's really about
the application
of how we're sort of applying
the foundational methodology
in many ways.
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
And so a question here--
when I'm looking at the group
and just knowing the culture at
Google, a lot of the employees
here are performance-driven
and, to say the least, very
time-starved, I think, as well.
What do you see people like us--
what are the biggest
mistakes you see us making?
MATT DIXON: I think it's two.
I think it's two things.
The first is for the
training athlete,
so someone that would
identify themselves as saying,
you know, I love
to run marathons,
or I like to do triathlons.
And for that type of person,
where they identify themselves
as an amateur athlete,
the biggest mistake
is, as I mentioned
at the top, thinking
that success in your
training program
is actually being able
to achieve a fixed number
of training hours per week.
So your barometer at
success is the accumulation
of time or miles.
That's the first thing
because that ends up leading.
That doesn't mesh.
We always talk about life
not being a spreadsheet.
And so life is dynamic.
It's dirty.
It's vibrant.
And so when you've got this
living, breathing, thing,
and you're trying to apply a
fixed number of training hours
every single week,
bad decisions start
to come into play, where
you're compromising components
like health, recovery, and
overall hormonal success.
So the thirst for the
athletic-minded is that.
For the fitness
enthusiast, so the person
that understands that exercise
is important and wants
to be healthy and wants
to thrive and have it
as a part of their
life, the challenge,
or I think the
biggest mistake, is
to be too singularly
focused on one element
that we're talking about.
So you might have someone
that says, I really
want to improve
body composition,
so I'm going to
eat really clean.
And I'm going to
eat really healthy.
And that's great.
But if it's not supported
with some strength
and with some endurance, or
if your sleep is terrible,
you're not going to improve
your body composition.
Or you have someone--
so the classic, that
loves to exercise.
But everything else is terrible.
Well, you're not going
to yield any performance
gains when you go from that.
DERK DE KORVER: Right.
Do you have any, like, live
examples you could give?
MATT DIXON: On the spot?
Thank you, Derk.
Sure.
I mean, I'll give you a great
example, someone that I started
working with a few months
ago, the classic person
that I tend to work with--
time-starved executive that
wants to integrate
exercise into his life.
And he understands,
emotionally understands,
that performance
in the workplace
is going to be helped if he
can exercise consistently.
So he made that commitment--
I'm going to work out
five days a week, period.
But when we actually
looked at what
he was doing with
his habits, he was
making sure he was getting
up every morning, typically
at 5:00 AM, working out
for 60 to 75 minutes.
But then it was
straight to work.
And the habits that
he'd created is
as soon as he
finished his session,
whether it was strength or
whether it was endurance,
he would shower, straight
to work, not have breakfast.
As he said, I buy a
breakfast sandwich
on the way to the
work, and it's sitting
on the desk at the
end of the day.
And then he would go
through his workday.
And so he was implementing
a single-focused positive
exercise.
But by underfueling
following, he
was setting off
catastrophic events
that were going to
disrupt carrying
stress hormones into the day.
So when you exercise
appropriately,
you have cortisol to help
you perform in the exercise.
But if you don't fuel
following, you're
not going to suppress,
naturally suppress, cortisol.
So you're carrying those
elevated cortisol levels
into your work day.
So that disrupts energy balance.
You're also going to set
off something-- what I like
to call athletic starvation.
So what that is, is
your body's in deficit.
You don't replace the
deficit because you're not
fueling following.
And so therefore,
later in the day,
you have really big challenges
around portion control
and the types of food that
you're getting cravings for.
So my executive--
I'll call him Johnny
because his name
is Johnny, but who
shall remain nameless, I think.
But as he got to the later day,
of course, he got to lunch.
And what did he crave?
Pasta, pizza, cookies,
ice cream because his body
was calling out for its
protective mechanism.
And then he can't
control his cravings.
He's in a slump.
He eats them.
What happens in the afternoon?
He's really sleepy.
So there's this massive
stress symptom going on.
There's an inability
to eat properly.
There's energy
fluctuations in the day.
And guess what?
He was retaining
body fat because when
he eats that pasta in the
middle of the day, that's
being stored as fat.
So it's one singular example
of not joining the dots.
He did something positive, but
without a very basic habit,
everything was falling apart.
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
No, I can definitely
relate to that example.
I'm not Johnny, though.
So OK, I think we all understand
that and probably have
experienced it, as well.
So what are the biggest
challenges to manage that,
in your opinion?
MATT DIXON: I think that for
busy people like you guys,
it's an understanding
of what to focus on.
And so how do I
take first steps?
And what I mean by that is
in the world we live in now,
we're not short of information.
We have so much information
coming at us from all angles,
even if you think
about the four subjects
that we talked about--
endurance, strength, nutrition,
and recovery.
How much information is
there about all of these?
And yet all of those
individual subjects--
and we make it up
to one recipe--
is really prone to
life-hacking and quick fixes
and quackery and stuff that
is really, really confusing.
So most people don't lack
motivation if they sort of
have a performance mindset.
But the challenge is that they
don't know what to focus on.
That's the first real challenge
that most people face.
So how do we overcome the
challenge of where to focus?
And the interesting thing is the
actual result is really basic.
So conceptually, it's
relatively appealing.
But the actual habits
that you want to integrate
are actually really basic.
But then you have to
acknowledge, as well,
that the second challenge
is, great, I have a plan.
I understand.
And now life happens.
And the management
of decision-making
of when to push through
when you're tired,
when to scale back, when to
backdrop, how do we do it when
life gets in the way and we
have to manage with travel
or components of that?
That's where it becomes
really challenging.
So I'd say the two
main challenges
that we face are
what to focus on--
so filtering
information-- and then
how to actually manage
it in real life.
And I find as a
coach, education is
important to
empower the athlete.
But a part of my role, a
critical part of my role,
from pros all the way down
to people that would never
compete in any sort
of structured event,
is becoming a filter
of that information.
Because there's so
much crap out there.
Let's face it.
And so if you can
create a filter,
then it becomes
actually quite simple.
That that's the good
news out of all of this,
is that you can actually get
to pretty simple solutions that
are long-term, I
would say, overall.
DERK DE KORVER: All right.
So basically what you're saying
there is in these scenarios,
when battling with
these challenges,
you're pushing athletes-- or
even if we're not athletes--
to adopt an athletic mindset.
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
DERK DE KORVER: I've heard
you say that quite often.
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
DERK DE KORVER:
So how would you--
MATT DIXON: What is
the athletic mindset?
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
MATT DIXON: Yeah,
I think that we
talk a lot about the
athletic mindset.
And what it is not about
is trying to turn everyone
into an athlete.
That's not we're
actually trying to do.
An athletic mindset is actually
drawing off of the lessons
that we have from our
living laboratory, which
are professional athletes, where
we can look at how training
methodology affects them,
how great supporting habits
actually helps them
thrive, and then
applying it to everyday
people, everyday people
that high performance.
But adopting an
athletic mindset doesn't
mean that you're trying
to become an athlete.
Because most of you guys in
here, if not all of you guys,
are not elite athletes and
probably don't have aspirations
to be an elite athlete.
But you are an elite performer.
At least you should
be an elite performer
because I believe that
your quest, hopefully,
is that you want to integrate
a healthy lifestyle so that you
can feel good and be the best
version of yourself for as many
years as we have on this place.
But in addition to that, you
are an elite performer in here,
in Google.
And you have a
responsibility to be
able to perform at your
best in the workplace,
and then leave this workplace,
and perform the best that you
can for your family,
friends, and everything else.
And so we are not trying to
turn people into athletes.
What we're trying
to have them do
is adopt an athletic mindset
so that they can thrive
across their institutions.
And those major institutions
is yes, improving sport,
whatever your endeavor is.
And it might just be
going to the bike club
and doing exercise, but also
in your health, in your ability
to perform in the workplace,
and, of course, outside of life
with family and friends.
And we know-- it comes back.
We know that it has to
be a holistic lens where
we draw on the
lessons of the pros
to actually facilitate success.
And that's really the basic
tenet of everything that we do,
in many ways.
DERK DE KORVER: And
building on that,
what are some of the results
that you aim for people
adopting an athletic mindset?
MATT DIXON: I'm going
to come to a word that's
going to sound quite bizarre.
I'm going to talk about control.
And before I talk
about control, I
think it's important to
understand-- earlier,
I mentioned life hacks.
There is no sugarcoating this.
When we sort of talk about,
without being obsessive,
if you do want to thrive, there
is no shortcut to success.
There is an ongoing journey
that you have to embrace.
And so that's why I never
talk about quick results.
I don't talk about going on
diets and all those things
because all of that
reeks of short term.
So it's mostly based
in habit driven.
And when we see people
integrate positive habits,
a few things occur.
And those habits, again,
are around endurance,
strength, recovery,
and nutrition.
But when they integrate over the
long term, they always improve.
But what ends up happening about
just what is improvement is,
I think, that you
start to establish
an element of control.
And what I mean by control
is you start to establish,
yes, you've got
performance improvements
in your sport, whatever
your sport might be.
So you get fitter,
stronger, faster.
And that's almost
a great byproduct.
But the really positive things
is control over your energy
management in the day.
So if you can start to
have predictable energy
throughout the course
of the workday,
that's a great element.
You start to have control
over your body composition,
so actually coming to a better
place of homeostasis or health
around body composition.
And then some of the I
would say almost secondary,
but in a work-performance
environment that's
really critical, is this word
resilience or robustness.
People become more
physically robust
or resilient to stresses.
And so when they do go
through a lack of sleep
with time zone
travel, or they have
to be up late for
a presentation,
and they're getting compromised
sleep, whatever it might be,
there is a physical resilience
that still enables them
to perform in the short term.
And then added to that
is emotional resilience.
So people become better
equipped at being
able to manage stressful
situations because
of these habits.
And there is a direct link,
proven by much research,
to show that this state of
well-being equips you for that.
So it's pretty easy
to think about, OK,
if I've got management
over my energy,
and I'm more robust
and able to deal
with adversity and
different physical
and emotional stresses,
that's going to equip you
to ultimately-- yeah,
I'm getting faster
or whatever my endeavor
is in a sporting sense.
But I'm just a better
performer in life.
And the final
effect is happiness.
And when someone actually
really adopts this mindset,
whether it's guided by
myself, Purple Patch, or not,
I've yet to see someone
that hasn't actually
reported improved happiness.
Because we are all happier if we
are under control of our life.
And that's really the ultimate
sense that we're looking for
and the outcome that
we're looking for.
So as a triathlon coach,
the leap that people make
is that when I'm helping the
majority of our Purple Patch
athletes, which are
time-starved amateurs,
it's just about how
fast you can go,
or can you qualify to Hawaii?
And those goals are great.
But the real results
that you're looking for
is to set people
free and empowered
to actually have management over
the other institutions in life.
If you can do that,
the recipe is right,
and the sporting side's easy.
So don't be overly impressed
that you got fourth in Hawaii
last year, Derk.
That was the easy part.
DERK DE KORVER:
Thank you for that.
No, I definitely hear you
on all those points there.
I also really notice
how the reward
of working for
something really hard,
how that carries over
into life and work.
And I've learned the
hard way, as well,
and maybe the most costly
way, that there's no shortcuts
to speed in triathlon.
It's just really expensive
if you want to get faster.
Got to buy all the [INAUDIBLE]
components and whatnot.
But let's get a
little practical here.
I know that we don't
have time to outline
a full plan for everybody here.
But what are some of
the key need-to-knows
when creating a
plan for yourself
and approaching training?
MATT DIXON: Luckily, there
is a plan in the book.
So you guys can enjoy that.
So it's a tough question, Derk.
I knew you'd ask
me this question.
And in many ways, it depends
on what our goals are.
So do we have Derk, who's trying
to go to the Hawaii Ironman
again and qualify and get
on the podium, et cetera,
or someone just trying
to integrate exercise
into their life?
But there are some common
themes that I can touch on.
The first, the most
important thing,
is whatever your recipe
is, your training
plan is, it has to have this
magic word, sustainability.
It has to be sustainable.
And another way of saying that
from an exercise standpoint
is habitual.
It has to become
something that you do.
So if your endurance
activity or your training
is like a monkey on the
back, it's not sustainable.
And you will fall into that
trap of being fit and fatigued.
When we think about performance
in an athletic sense,
the first word that we come
up with is consistency.
And so that's the
first element we do.
So as I talked about
earlier, what most people do,
athletes that are
building their own plans
or receiving plans from coaches,
unfortunately, is to say,
great.
I want to exercise, or I
want to go and do a marathon,
or I want to go and
do a half Ironman.
How many hours a week
do I have to train?
And the coach loyally writes
them a training program.
And they say, this is it.
It's 15 hours a week of
training to get ready
for a half Ironman.
And then what they do
is they say, great.
How am I going to fit
this into my life?
And they look at their
life, and they think,
I don't have that many hours.
But they do their darndest to
cram it in by hook or crook.
So what happens there?
They compromise sleep.
They comprise basic habits.
And the sport becomes
a monkey on their back.
Their partner starts
to detest the sport,
and there's lots of tension.
And they become rightly labeled
as the obsessive triathlete.
Well, that's the antithesis
of what you want to do.
So instead, I think
you want to start
at the other side
of the equation.
And we have athletes
always go through this--
and I should have a
better name for it.
But it's always sometimes
rarely projects,
where we're looking to actually
get a true understanding
of the landscape of your life.
How many hours a week
do you genuinely have?
So when can you always exercise?
When can you sometimes exercise?
And when can you rarely?
If life ebbs a
little bit, you might
have places to add in there.
That's the first thing
that you go through.
And then you start to get an
understanding of how many hours
you have.
But we have to also plug
in time for yourself,
time for your family, if you've
got a husband, wife, kids,
et cetera, time for
sleep, because that's
a non-negotiable.
So you have to
plug in your sleep.
And some social life, because
we would like you to be social.
Now you have X number
of hours a week.
And it's typically less hours,
but they're realistic hours,
than you may have
thought that you had.
But then the game becomes,
how do I maximize those hours?
And just by starting with
that very basic approach,
you can then calendar those
hours into your work schedule,
no different than a meeting,
and you're set up for success.
Part two to it,
then, is you have
to deploy a dynamic mindset.
What I mean by a
dynamic mindset is
if that is your best-laid plans,
as I mentioned before, life
doesn't act like that.
It's not a spreadsheet.
So the next thing
you have to do is
you have to create a
tier of specificity.
And we always have,
no matter whether it's
fitness enthusiasts or Derk,
the amateur triathlete, or one
of my pros, we have key
sessions, which are typically
the more intense,
the more challenging,
and the ones that are
delivering the specificity.
And then we have
supporting sessions.
And those are the ones that
are nice to add in, great
if you have time, but are the
first to be scaled or removed
if life gets in the way.
And what that creates,
then, is a starting
of a management system.
Because if you're
traveling to New York
if you're based
in San Francisco,
and you can move
sessions around and hang
onto your key sessions, but
you might lose or reduce
some of the supporting
sessions without guilt
because it's appropriate.
On the flip side,
family goes away.
I have Friday off work.
You can now add on
some extra sessions
because life has ebbed, and
you've got more capacity.
And now you've got
this very basic sort
of synchronized mindset of
training with a prioritization.
And that becomes incredibly
powerful for athletes
and fitness enthusiasts
to ultimately create
what I would call a recipe
for success, in many ways.
DERK DE KORVER:
For a moment there,
I thought you were
telling my life story.
I've definitely gone
through that phase where
triathlon took over my life.
And friends and
family definitely
let me know that
that was happening.
And yeah, you do need to
sort of try and fit it in.
So I'm happy to say I have
a good balance now, I think.
And so to get the most
bang for your buck,
are you saying
interval trainings?
Ram them?
MATT DIXON: Yeah, certainly key.
Look, if you're
time-starved, don't worry
about accumulation of hours.
Hit high intensity.
But we can't, from a
musculoskeletal standpoint
and a hormonal level, we can't
do high intensity every day.
And so I think you have
a couple of times a week
that you're going to go--
even if you're just a fitness
enthusiast-- very
high-intensity training.
It's good for you.
You also want to have
strength training.
And strength training doesn't
need to dominate your life.
But 20 to 30 minutes, if
you're more endurance-focused,
is incredibly powerful
and a great what I
would call critical supplement.
If you're more
strength-inclined,
then it could become a
bit more institutional.
But strength training.
And then supporting
sessions are lower stress.
But they still have
variance in them.
Another magic word of
performance is variance.
So we always want to have--
whenever you're doing a thing
that's just steady state--
so in England, we
call it milquetoast--
just always looking at some kind
of variance would be the key.
DERK DE KORVER: Thanks for
those insights on training.
But you also have other
pillars that you highlight--
hydration, fueling, rest.
Anything that you could
share regarding that?
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
If we now allow recipe
of strength and endurance
as an athlete, my mindset--
or a fitness enthusiast--
you are less than 50% of the
way there to your solution.
And so you have two
other big pillars
you have to think about without
becoming a monk or obsessive
and without falling
for fad diets.
So under the pillar
of nutrition,
you can break it down
into three key elements.
The first is your fueling.
The second is your nutrition,
your daily eating habits.
And the third is your hydration.
So I'll do a
quick-and-dirty on them.
Fueling-- exercising
60 minutes or less,
you don't need to
take in calories.
No matter what
Gatorade will tell you,
you don't need to
take in calories.
OK?
Under 60 minutes or less.
What you do have to
do is if exercise
is really long or really
intense and a little bit longer,
than sugar is your
friend on that component
because it helps
performance during.
But the nonnegotiable,
whether you're taking calories
during the workout or
not, the nonnegotiable,
every single time
you exercise, you
have to consume calories
following a workout.
And as much as possible,
it should be real food.
So you want to have
protein because that's
going to bring down cortisol
and it's going to kick-start
your recovery process.
You want to have
some carbohydrate
because that's going to
restore your energy packets.
And especially if you
exercise in the morning,
that's going to actually
facilitate your recovery,
as well.
And you want to do it as
quickly as we possibly
can after the workout.
Because if we do
that, it's going
to avoid that
athletic starvation
that we talked about.
It's going to set
up better eating
habits in the rest of your day.
And it's going to elicit
your best chance to yield
adaptations and consistency over
your training or your exercise,
as well as your recovery
from that exercise.
So it becomes, I would say, the
number-one performance habit,
even for just
fitness enthusiasts--
consuming calories
immediately following.
If you do that well, and
only if you do that well--
so if you don't do, it
you are failing, period.
If you take one
thing from today,
consume calories
following exercise.
If you do that well, and then
in the rest of your daily eating
habits, sugar is
not your friend.
Sugar, we know, has a
precursor to diabetes,
one of the big causes
for increasing obesity
rates in Western countries.
And unfortunately, to
put it in another way,
if you eat sugar when
your metabolic rate is
low in the rest of
the day, it's going
to go straight to your hips.
OK?
So reduce or eliminate sugar.
You don't need, if
we're fueled well,
too many starchy carbohydrates.
And instead, we lean into
a platform of health.
So it's very simple--
nutrient-dense foods, lots of
proteins, lots of good fats,
and too many vegetables that are
very colorful that you've never
imagined that even existed
as vegetables, eat as many
of as you can.
So that's the nutrition.
And then finally, hydration.
That your energy juice.
That is your energy juice, high
hydration throughout the day.
Ignore hydration
during exercise.
That's valuable and good.
But when you're
sitting here at Google,
daily hydration will have a huge
impact on your energy levels
and sustainable energy
levels in the day.
And when you're
sitting here and you're
working, if you start to
feel sleepy or hungry,
it's either because you're
athletically starved,
or, more typically,
because you're dehydrated.
And, of course, the kickback
that I get when I say this is,
yes, but I have to always go for
a pee, and it disrupts my work.
OK, yeah, you need to shift
the lens on what that is.
Because that's a
performance break.
Sitting is the
new smoking, yeah?
There is lots of
research to show
that we perform our best
work when we actually
work in 45 to 75
minutes of great focus.
So if you're peeing
every hour, that's
a chance to move
your body, which
is better for your
longevity and your health.
You're going to have
better decision-making
and focus because
you're not in a slump.
You move your body,
and you get to pee.
So you get to be social.
You get to actually talk
to people in the bathroom.
What more can you dream off?
But I think shifting the lens
is really, really important.
And then there was
one more pillar, yeah?
DERK DE KORVER: Rest?
MATT DIXON: Recovery, yeah.
DERK DE KORVER: OK.
MATT DIXON: Should
I talk about that?
DERK DE KORVER: Yes, please.
MATT DIXON: Let me give
you the quick and dirty
because recovery is now a trendy
sort of subject for athletes.
And all of you guys
here have sort of
probably read about
or participated
in meditation and components
like that, which are
part of the recovery process.
So when I think about recovery,
if you are an athlete,
there are basically three
main buckets of recovery
that we have to consider.
That's sport-specific--
so if you're
an athlete, that's how you're
structuring blocks of rest
into your season, breaks
from the sport, how you're
integrating easier
days of training
into any block of work,
and maybe sometimes
actually having a
complete day off of rest.
So they're sport-specific,
which most athletes say,
that's my recovery.
But there are two other key
subjects we have to consider--
what we call lifestyle
and modalities.
So your lifestyle is your sleep,
your number-one recovery tool.
You are only going to hear
more and more about sleep
over the coming years.
It is incredibly powerful.
And there are lots of
research-- in fact,
just this week, the
"Harvard Business Review"
came out with a interesting
research-based article on very
high-end executives
prioritizing sleep
relative to mid-managerial
type executives.
But sleep is a huge
component, both in terms
of not just your quantity,
but your quality of sleep.
So that is a powerful recovery
tool that cannot be compromised
for longevity of
high performance,
sporting or otherwise.
Then there is
actually nutrition.
And a platform of daily
eating facilitates recovery
and, as we talked about
earlier, your fueling.
And then the final two
I think you can cojoin,
which is your naps
and meditation.
And if you haven't heard about
it yet, you should or you will.
But there is no
doubt that while it
used to be viewed
as hippy-dippy,
meditation is an important
component of recovery
and global performance.
And that doesn't mean
that you have to sit
in Lotus Position and meditate.
For many people, that's
just finding a quiet space
for seven to 15 minutes a day,
often in the middle of the day,
and being quiet.
And you might fall
asleep, hence the nap.
And you stimulate growth hormone
and other positive effects.
And it has a huge impact on your
productivity in the afternoon,
and research shows it.
So you are allowed to be a sloth
in the middle of the day for 10
minutes.
And that might be listening to
Headspace or one of those apps.
Or it might just be
getting into a quiet place,
or even going for a walk
without your screens
and grounding yourself.
And it's really powerful.
So that's the second
component of recovery.
And then the final
is modalities.
So modalities is everything
that they sell you--
massage, compression
socks, cryotherapy
and other trendy things that,
heat treatments, foam roller,
everything.
And that's another
part of recovery.
So those are the big sort
of families we think about.
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
I think my favorite is
definitely the napping.
I try to get that in.
And luckily at Google, we have
some really nice nap pods.
So if you're not using those,
I recommend that you do.
But which would you say is the
most important among those?
MATT DIXON: The ones that
we're pushed the most,
and all the marketing
drives us to,
is framed in the
mindset of shortcuts.
So wear compression socks.
Go to the local place
and get cryotherapy.
Make sure you have
body work done.
And all of that stuff
is good, the modalities.
But it is down there, absolutely
down there in importance.
If you don't get an appropriate
training program with enough
of recovery integrated into it--
again, training, even if
you're a fitness enthusiast,
not exercise.
Exercise is random.
Training is targeted.
So your training, even if
you're a fitness enthusiast,
appropriate program for
you, that's number one.
And supported with enough
sleep and, I would say,
proper fueling and nutrition.
That is the most
important thing.
If we can get that, we
call it nailing the basics.
And our mantra
for our pro squad,
you would imagine that it's
all about equipment and wind
tunnels and aerodynamics.
Our mantra is
nailing the basics.
Get those things right.
If you get those things right--
so an appropriate
training program
applied consistently,
supported with proper nutrition
and enough sleep--
you are-- and this is
thoughtful when I say this--
95% of the way there.
Everything else is
fluff, incremental.
So when you think
about it, it's always
based in those
very basic habits.
And it's not about being a monk.
It's not about
falling for fad diets.
It's really about trying to
institute very basic habits.
And that's the nice thing,
is a shift in mindset
to say a bit of, I'm going
old-school in a positive way.
Because I'm just going
to build myself up
with very foundational
habits globally.
DERK DE KORVER: Thanks, Matt.
I do realize that we're
sort of running out of time.
And I want to keep plenty
of time for the Q&A.
You did just launch a book.
So maybe we can switch
gears there and just
talk about that
for a little bit.
Would you say that
that's geared towards
the obsessed triathlete?
MATT DIXON: Yeah,
trying to break
the obsession of triathletes.
Yes, so it is a book
about triathlon.
And it's specifically designed--
this is not for my
very elite amateur
with lots of time in the world
or my professional athletes
that are looking to achieve
world-class performance.
This is about high performance
in my sport, triathlon,
but extending it to really
what we talked about today.
So how can you draw from this?
So I actually think--
in fact, I've had a couple
of very elite running coaches
and a cycling coach
ask for this book
and read it, not to understand
how we train for triathlons,
but how to actually integrate
the supporting habits to help
them help their athletes.
And so I think it's really
designed specifically
for endurance-focused people
that are time starved,
that are looking for the very
utopian outcome of thriving.
And yes, in my sport--
and in our case in
this book, triathlon.
But also in those
other institutions
that we talked about, which
is work, life, and health.
And so I don't want
to say I'm going
to be writing another
book because I
haven't been asked yet.
But the next book would probably
be taking this and making
it more global and saying, hey,
it's about performance in life
and whatever your sport is.
But this one's certainly
for triathletes.
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
I've read it, and
I really love it.
I think you give some
great case studies
and inspirational
examples of people
that you've worked with
and seen them succeed.
And your writing style is
just like you-- very serious,
but with a wink.
So yeah, thank you.
Maybe one last question.
You've worked with a
wide variety of athletes.
What would you say
you're most proud of?
MATT DIXON: I think as a
coach that gets to coach elite
athletes, it's very
hard to sort of look
beyond when one of our athletes
was second at the Hawaii
Ironman as a professional.
And that was a real breakout
moment for us back in 2009.
And then in 2016, when
Tim Reed in Australia,
one of our athletes, won
the world championships,
the half Ironman world
championships, that's
obviously great and a part of
what I live for, in many ways.
You know, that's a great thing.
And having Laura win
this last weekend,
and in such a
historic race, she's
the first British athlete,
male or female, to ever win
Ironman New Zealand.
That's great.
But in all honesty, a couple
of athletes spring to mind.
One athlete that came to
me who couldn't walk up
a flight of stairs and had
chronic fatigue so badly.
She'd actually lost her
daughter in a car crash
and went through a terrible
place, put on 100 pounds,
and three years later has
now finished a half Ironman.
And her whole life
has turned around.
She's 100 pounds lighter.
And that for me
is the application
of a methodology in
a very different way.
And then some of the
inspirational people
that I've got to work with, the
sort of captains of industry
that are ultimately
thriving in the workplace,
but I would say certainly
not thriving in the rest
of their life.
I mean, not very
healthy, and been
able to turn it around and
enable them to not only improve
as an extremely
time-starved individual,
but also have it bring
and spawn into their life.
So for me, the pride
component comes
with seeing people thrive
more than actually saying,
I coached a world
champion, which is nice.
But it's not why
we live, you know?
So it's only triathlon.
It's only that big.
The world is this big.
DERK DE KORVER: Wonderful.
Thanks.
Thanks, Matt.
I'd like to open up to the
floor now for some Q&A.
MATT DIXON: Oh, we
don't have a microphone.
DERK DE KORVER: And
again, for those
joining through
live stream, I'll
be looking at the Dory for you
to submit some questions there.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
just want to thank you
because you're a
tri-coach, obviously
a very accomplished tri-coach.
And we've talked about
triathlons for an hour,
and you haven't mentioned VO2
max or lactate testing, which
I feel like are usually
the first two things out
of tri-coaches mouths.
So I love--
I haven't read the
book, but I want to.
And I love your approach to it.
I'd just love to know the
legacy ways of training
for Ironman races, which include
lactate testing and V02 max
and periodization,
stuff like that--
does your method still
call for a lot of that?
Is it putting that
in perspective?
Or is it really more just about
personalized plans and finding
what's right for folks like
us, the time-starved athletes.
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
The-- I call it
paralysis of analysis
and the metrics obsessed.
And it's all about focusing
on the wrong thing.
So I'll give you a
couple of examples.
Bear in mind that I'm an
exercise physiologist.
So I've probably done 1,000
blood lactate tests and too
many V02 tests and
everything along those lines.
But there is a lot of that
magic word, periodization,
that we hear.
So let's think about
applying periodization.
So in the winter months,
you want to build your base.
You want to get
really fit, and you
want to become a
better butter burner.
So you want to do a lot
of low-intensity training.
And yet nearly everyone in
the winter months, the days
are short, and it's freezing
cold, and you're stuck inside.
It doesn't fit life, firstly.
So it's upside down.
And on top of that, if
you are a triathlete,
you're going to accumulate
naturally all of your riding
and running miles,
the longer stuff,
outside when the weather's nice.
And it's an endurance sport.
So the puzzle when
applied to everyday people
is completely upside-down.
But with things like VO2 max and
those assessments and metrics,
data is a great thing.
It's good to capture data.
It's good to utilize it,
sometimes on the fly,
and certainly as an
objective review.
But you cannot be
shackled by data.
Because what has happened
with the advent of monitoring
is people lose the inner
animal and sense of self.
And so even when
we're prescribing,
we prescribe intensity
by the intention,
what it should feel like, what
the perceived effort should be.
And as a byproduct or
an alignment of that,
this is about your power
our pace of heart right.
So it's at the other end
of the equation again.
So none of it is bad.
It's an understanding
of physiology.
But I much prefer
[? boiling ?] complex to simple
rather than run it--
I can impress everyone
with long terms.
But that doesn't actually--
it doesn't resonate.
It's not real-world.
And so let's bring it down to
really approachable and basic
habits to make
people successful.
In fact, my race
plan for Tim Reed,
who won the world championship,
was go and have fun.
Because he was an athlete
that was so-- you would think
it was so granular.
But he gets very
nervous before races.
And it was a bit more
than go and have fun.
But he was so prepared, and
he knew so much what to do
and how to feel, that I wanted
to release him to just make
smart decisions on the day.
And the world championships
was in Australia.
And it was in his hometown.
So I just said, that
will never happen again,
to have a world championship
in your hometown.
So don't let the
moment bypass you.
Go and have fun.
There's that phrase.
And what that did was
that gave him permission
to just relax and go and
race at the purest sense.
I never talked to him about
what power to hold or pace.
His body was trained to do that.
He did run pretty fast.
He didn't need me to
tell him to run faster.
DERK DE KORVER: Wonderful.
I have one question
here on the Dory
from Johan in Mountain
View, who's actually
a really good triathlete.
I know him.
What kind of impact
have you seen
from people integrating
nutrition, sleep, et cetera
correctly in their
training programs?
Is it a decrease in
time from, let's say,
a 9 hour 10 Iron Man to 9 hours?
Or have you seen
even bigger changes?
MATT DIXON: No.
Well, I'll give you a
professional athlete that was--
I coached a woman that
when she came to me
had already done
20 Ironman races.
And her fastest time
was 11 and 1/2 hours.
And by creating more
specificity in her training--
this is an extreme example--
but most importantly shifting
nutrition and making her sleep,
she went to going under 9 hours.
So that's when you start to
get pretty fast, by the way.
If you're a female athlete
going under 9 hours,
you're pretty good.
And went on to win, I
think, eight or nine
professional Ironman wins.
It is seismic.
And it's everything.
And so the results vary.
Because it's not just about
how fast you're going.
It's the bigger
picture, as well.
Injuries and interruptions to
training and sustainability
and enjoyment of the sport
and people exiting the sport
are also equally, I
think, really important.
Yeah.
DERK DE KORVER: Yeah.
Just a live example
myself-- since adopting
this methodology, I
knocked off 30 minutes
from my Ironman time.
So really, nailing the basics,
I think, is really important.
MATT DIXON: Without,
certainly, training more.
DERK DE KORVER: No, no.
MATT DIXON: That's with
training probably less hours.
DERK DE KORVER:
No, I've probably
been asking for more hours
than you've been giving me.
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
DERK DE KORVER: Cool.
Any more questions
from the room?
Could we get the mic?
MATT DIXON: I will give you one
tip before I finish, as well.
OK.
I'll give everyone
one tip that I
think is important on energy
management that will help.
But go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
longevity and sustainability.
I moved up in age
bracket this year.
So have you noticed anything
in the people you coach, maybe,
that shift the pillars?
Like, I understand the pillars.
I love the pillars.
But any shifting in
terms of sustainability
for people who are just
moving up in age bracket?
MATT DIXON: Just because
you've burst into your 30s
doesn't mean that things change.
Yeah.
As you do get older,
the way that you train
shifts a little bit.
And so there has to be an
ever-increasing emphasis
on recovery.
And one of the
things that starts
to drop or become suppressed
is strength and mobility.
So we just make that--
it's almost turning
up the emphasis
on those two components
a little bit,
and then just being a little
careful with how frequently
you're hitting intensity.
But in the sport of
triathlon, specifically,
when you're hitting-- in
fact, the fastest age group
as an amateur is typically 40 to
45, which is bad news for you,
in some ways.
It's only going to get faster.
But-- yeah, that's your group.
But yeah, we have athletes
consistently getting
faster and faster and
faster into their 50s.
It's not till about
53, 54 that you start--
and it's so obviously not
just chronological age.
It's biological
expression of it.
But that's where things just
start to drop off a little bit.
But it also depends on how
long you've been in the sport.
So if you've been doing
the sport for 15 years,
you have to make
a radical shift.
If you're two years in, you can
probably just treat yourself
like a 30-year-old
in many ways, apart
from not compromising sleep.
That's a really key component.
DERK DE KORVER: Cool.
Thanks, Matt.
We are at time, actually.
MATT DIXON: Yeah.
DERK DE KORVER: I know you had
one last little tip, if you
want to throw that out there.
MATT DIXON: I'll give you
that one very quick and dirty
because it's something that
I often have with people that
are time-starved
and working, which
is the afternoon energy slumps.
So this has nothing
to do with triathlon.
But for you guys still in
the room or watching live,
this is something that I think
is worthy of understanding.
So who has afternoon energy
slumps sometimes at 3 o'clock?
So the thing that
people reach for
is either, many people,
Monster or Red Bull or Coke
or coffee, yeah?
So that's not the
thing that's actually
going to create the
result. What is actually
happening there-- so as soon as
you understand the physiology,
it's a breakthrough for you.
You have your circadian rhythm.
Everyone understands that.
When you go to bed at night,
your body actually slows down,
and it cools.
And that's really restorative.
Well, the Spanish had it
right with their siestas
because in the afternoon,
we have a natural circadian
rhythm where your body
starts to cool a little bit.
And it starts to go into
a restorative phase.
So your core
temperature is dropping.
And the byproduct of
that is sleepiness.
So you start to get tired.
So what you want is you don't
want to ingest caffeine there
that might disrupt sleep and
hence start the vicious cycle.
All you need is hot liquid.
So if you just have hot water
with lemon or mint tea or even
chamomile tea that you identify
with relaxation, something
that's hot, it's going to
raise your core temperature,
and it will improve
your alertness
for the next multiple hours
without interrupting sleep.
So that's my last tip
because if you go and do
that when you feel tired
tomorrow, go and have mint tea.
And you'll be like, hang on.
That actually works,
and I didn't have sugar
that's a short-term spike.
And I didn't have
caffeine that's
going to interrupt sleep later.
It's just hot liquid.
So for you guys that have
to perform in the workplace,
that's often maybe a
nice way to finish.
DERK DE KORVER: Wonderful.
Thank you so much, Matt.
MATT DIXON: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]